one quiet summer afternoon the whole
town seemed to be asleep
but the strangest noises are coming from
the Smith house is there something the
matter with jr.
Jr has cut his first tooth
his parents are proud Roger thinks teeth
for chewing with
but you can't choose celery with only
one tooth
one tooth is like a pair of scissors
with only one blade it won't cut but
front teeth in the top jaw and front
teeth in the bottom jaw can cut the food
into little pieces like a pair of
scissors back teeth are like nutcrackers
they crush the food like a mortar and
pestle they grind it but we must help
our teeth to do their job of cutting
crushing and grinding teeth need care to
keep them healthy and well just as the
body does teeth must be healthy to chew
properly unhealthy teeth are bad for
horses
ginger gives his teeth help the Smiths
help their teeth by eating raw carrots
and celery and apples and salad Jr does
his best on a biscuit afterwards mr.
Smith has some news to mock they will go
on a picnic
Roger and his excitement almost forgets
that after eating tiny bits of food
remain in the mouth and cause tooth
decay and though you can't see it the
tooth rots day by day but if time were
speeded up you could watch the tooth
ding
and if the holes get really big often
the tooth must come out the other teeth
try to fill in the empty space and when
the teeth are in the wrong places it's
difficult to chew but Roger knows he can
help cut down decay by brushing away the
small bits of food right after eating he
could even brush his teeth while
thinking of the picnic and soak in the
rest of the family
after they've eaten right away they
brushed their teeth to help stop decay
after breakfast lunch and supper it
doesn't take long to keep your teeth
clean it leaves plenty of time to get
ready for the picnic and all the Smiths
are busy all except Roger and Roger is
trying to help his teeth decay by eating
candy but mrs. Smith stop and --which
instead for sweets cause decay
the picnic the picnic thinks Roger as he
finishes a sandwich and goes to bed the
picnic the picnic
there's something else you should think
about - ginger is trying to help him
remember
sandwich toothbrush
Roger remembers just in time to use his
toothbrush right after eating
next morning it's beautiful weather for
the picnic
The Smiths can hardly wait to start
but they must make one stop on the way
for the car to be checked for cars like
teeth should always be checked before
trouble begins
now the Smiths are really on their way
to the country
and what a wonderful picnic it is
there's milk there are apples and
oranges there are brown bread sandwiches
of tomatoes there are radishes and brown
bread sandwiches of meat for these are
the foods which added together build
strong healthy teeth and because it is a
picnic and they didn't bring their
toothbrushes the Smiths
rinse their mouths with water to wash
away the little bits of food and keep
their teeth clean
after lunch the Smiths
all do the things they like to do in the
fresh air and Sun
Roger likes exploring
following ginger he meets a man sitting
under a tree he's a very nice man and he
throws sticks for ginger to fetch and he
picks the four-leaf clover and gives it
to Roger for lucky but just at that
moment a storm comes up
The Smiths packed their things and get
ready to go they all begin to shout for
Roger
why doesn't he hurry where can he be
here he comes running as fast as he can
next morning at breakfast Roger is
thinking about the man and the picnic so
he's not very interested when his mother
reminds him that this is the day he is
going to the dentist birthday once a
year dentist twice a year he'll have his
teeth checked in advance just as they
checked the car at the garage he doesn't
really want to go he'd sooner play with
ginger but a big surprise is in store
for him he finds that the dentist is his
very good friend who gave him the
four-leaf clover and there is hardly
anything the matter with his teeth for
Roger keeps them in good condition by
following four good rules he helps to
prevent decay by using his toothbrush
right after eating
he eats the food that builds strong
teeth it's as easy as two and two he
avoids too much candy especially between
meals because sweets can cause decay and
to make sure his teeth are healthy and
strong he visits the dentist twice a
year for rules like the four-leaf clover